MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, Karolina.
Welcome to "Serverless
Expeditions."
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ:
Thank you, Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER: You are a
Cloud Run product manager,
and I hear you've
worked in a way
to make Cloud Run
even more useful?
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ:
That's right.
We've released Cloud Run
Jobs, which makes it easier
to use Cloud Run for
unattended batch jobs,
like database migrations,
report generation, and so on.
MARTIN OMANDER: Can't wait
to hear more about it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ: Developers
like Cloud Run because it lets
you run containers
in a serverless way.
Containers are good
because they make
it easy to package up your
application and the libraries
it needs.
MARTIN OMANDER:
And serverless is
good because it means your cloud
provider worries about scaling
up and down, so you
don't have to, right?
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ: Right.
So far, you've been able to
trigger Cloud Run executions
on HTTP calls or
events, like a file
being added to Cloud Storage.
But there are some
workloads that
aren't well-suited for that.
MARTIN OMANDER: What
kind of workloads?
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ: Well, you
might have a database migration
or cleanup work, an
export or import process,
reports to generate, and so on.
These jobs need to run
unattended without an HTTP
request from a user.
Also, they should
run to completion.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, right.
Back in my sysadmin
days, I had many things
that weren't web servers,
like maintenance scripts.
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ: Exactly.
These jobs often
take longer than it
takes to process an HTTP
request or an event, typically
minutes instead of seconds.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
I remember setting
up a virtual machine
to run some of those scripts.
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ: Many
organizations do that,
but it's inefficient.
You have to manage and
configure the virtual machine,
and you have to remember to take
it down once your job finishes
or pay for it 24/7.
Also, it can't easily scale
up to run really large jobs.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, I
only used a virtual machine
for scripts like that because
there was no serverless way
of doing it back then.
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ:
Well, now there is.
It's called Cloud Run Jobs.
It's still serverless.
It's still running containers.
But it works better for
unattended workloads that
aren't triggered by HTTP calls.
MARTIN OMANDER:
That sounds good.
But I suspect it's still not
completely clear to everyone
how it works.
We are developers, and we
like to see code and a demo.
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ: Well, let's
hope the demo gods are with me.
Imagine a company receives
invoices from its vendors
as PDF files.
Here are a few examples of
what they might look like.
Every night, they want to
extract the vendor names
and totals from those PDFs so
their finance team can review
and approve them the next day.
MARTIN OMANDER: Got it.
I've built nightly
jobs like that before.
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ: Right.
Now here's the code.
This part reads
the invoice files
from Google Cloud Storage.
This part calls the Document
AI API to extract vendor names
and totals from each invoice.
This part writes the
invoice data to Firestore.
And, finally, this part
moves the processed invoices
to another folder so
they won't get picked up
next time the job runs.
MARTIN OMANDER: And,
once the job runs,
how will we see the
parsed invoice data?
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ: We also have
this simple web page that reads
the parsed invoice data from
Firestore and displays it
to the user.
MARTIN OMANDER: Got it.
Would we deploy the
invoice parsing job
like a regular
Cloud Run service?
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ:
It's similar.
You first build your container
with Google Cloud Build
and then create your job
with gcloud run jobs create.
Let me create it right now.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
This code you showed me does
not listen to HTTP calls.
So how do we get it to run?
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ: Well, you
can run it from the Google
Cloud Console or
the command line.
It's similar to running a
shell script on your computer,
but it runs in the cloud
and has access to all
your Google Cloud resources.
Let me do that now.
There it goes.
MARTIN OMANDER: Mhm.
Looks like something ran.
Can we see the
output of the job?
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ:
Let's have a look.
I'll go to the
simple web page that
displays the parsed
details from the invoices.
Looks like it captured
the invoice data.
MARTIN OMANDER: Nice.
But, Karolina, what if I want
to run a nightly job when I'm
not at my keyboard?
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ: Anything
that can call the Cloud Run
admin API can start the job,
including Cloud Scheduler.
Let's use Cloud Scheduler to
make our job run every night.
I go to Cloud Scheduler.
Create a new job.
Give it a name and
a region to run in.
Set a schedule for it to
run using crontab notation
and a time zone.
Click Continue.
Target type, HTTP.
Enter the Cloud Run admin
API endpoint to run your job.
You can find that in
the documentation.
And keep HTTP method as POST.
Now we have to give
Cloud Scheduler
permissions to start the job.
I click here to
pick OAuth token.
And then I select which
Service account Scheduler
should use to start the job.
I know this one has
sufficient permission.
You need a service account
that has the Cloud Run invoker
permission on the job.
Then I click Create.
Now the job will be run nightly.
You won't have to be at your
keyboard at midnight, Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER: That's a relief.
The code you showed me
processed one invoice at a time
in series.
If we have a thousand invoices,
that would take a long time.
Can we speed it up somehow?
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ: Yes.
You can tell Could Run Jobs to
start several parallel tasks.
Let's say you have
a thousand invoices
and you start 10 parallel tasks.
Your code can detect
what number task it is--
for example, 4 out of 10.
Then your code can process
its part of the total work.
For task number 4, that
would be invoices 301 to 400.
MARTIN OMANDER: Sounds very
useful for a large jobs,
like big old data
migration jobs that need
to process millions of records.
Do you have a code
example for that?
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ: Let's save
that for another video, Martin.
Also, it's all in
the documentation.
The link is in the description.
MARTIN OMANDER: Very good.
Thanks for showing us, Karolina.
And thank you,
everyone, for watching.
If you have questions
for Karolina or me,
let us know in the comments.
Also let us know if there are
other serverless topics you'd
like to hear about.
Until next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]